اسرائيليه اشارت الى تبادل اطلاق نار على
الحدود مع مصر جراء وصول مشتبه فيهم بينهم
مسلحون للمنطقه الحدوديه والمتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال بان نحو 20 مشتبها
فيهم بينه مسلحون وصلوا قبل قليل من مصر
الى المنطقه الحدوديه والاشاره ايضا الى
عده رصد عده اصابات ولم يتم الحديث حتى
الساعه عن انتهاء هذه العمليه غياب اي
بيان رسمي دكتور خليل عناني حتى الساعه هل
يؤشر الى شيء
لا ده جلال يعني للاسف الشديد نحن اعتدنا
خلال الفتره الماضيه على عدم وجود بيانات
رسميه مصريه توضح للجميع ماذا ما يحدث
يعني في اغلب الاحوال يتم اصدار بيان
مقتضب جدا من خلال بوست على الفيسبوك او
على تويتر من قبل المتحدث العسكري بدون
اعطاء تفاصيل وهذا جزء رئيسي من المشكله
ان هناك حاله تعميه عدم وضوح الى حد بعيد
عدم اعطاء فكره حول ملامسات ما يحدث على
قطاع غزه ما يحدث على الحدود المصريه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي لاتصور سيصدر بيان
خلال للفتره القادمه الا بعدما يتم اتضاح
الامر واتمنى ان يكون هناك بالفعل توضيح
لهذه المساله ان يخرج بيان بالتفاصيل هذه
العمليه بنتكلم على عمليه كما تفضلت جلال
واشارت 20 مشتبه به هذه العمليه قامت
بالهجوم وبالتالي هناك بلا شك هناك هناك
جماعات اخرى او مجموعات اخرى قامت بنوع من
الاسناد ونوع من الدعم لهذه المجموعه
وبالتالي بنتكلم على عمل غير بسيط او غير
محدود او عمل فردي كما جاء وشرت ل قبل
قليل في يونيو الماضي من خلال قيام الجندي
محمد صلاح بما قام به من خلال
اختراق الحدود وقتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيلين
بنتكلم على عمل على ما يبدو منظم اكثر
تنظيما في عمل جماعي في تخطيط له لو
بنتكلم على 20 مشتبه فبنت على جماعه لديها
قدره على التعبئه وعلى توفير سلاح دخول في
اشتباكات للا نعرف هل هناك اصابات ام لا
حتى هذهه اللحظه انا استبعد نوعا ما يكون
هؤلاء يعني نشرت قبل قليل بعض
السيناريوهات يعني لم اكن اعرف رقم
المشتبه بهم او رقم المتورطين او رقم
المهاجمين اعتقد انه ست ابعد يكون هؤلاء
من ضمن الجيش المصري في هذه المساله ممكن
نتكلم على مجموعه نظمت نفسها بشكل او اخر
نعلم جميعا جلال انه سيناء بها عدد من
الجماعات الجهاديه لحد بعيد طبعا
معظمها لا يشارك في عمليات ضد اسرائيل و
طبعا لغز كبير جدا حول نشط هذه العمليات
لكن بشكل او باخر ليس هناك احكام للسيطره
من قبل الحكومه المصريه على قطاع غزه ط
عفوا على سيناء وكما شار العميد الياس قبل
قليل لم يكن فقط هناك تنسيق مع اسرايل بل
ايضا هناك شراكه وهناك استخدام في بعض
الاوقات او قيام اسرائيل بطلعات جويه داخل
سيناء من اجل تعقب الجماعات الجهديه
بنتكلم على وجود تنظيم الوله هناك منذ عام
2014 طبعا قبله كان تنظيم التوحيد والجوي
وتنظيم القاعده الفر الفرع الخاص به في
مصر وبالتالي بنتكلم على منطقه هي بحد
ذاتها منطقه غير مستقره هناك حرب مستمره
على الاقل من 10 سنوات تم الدفع بقوات
مصريه من اجل محاربه الجماعات المتطرفه
هناك من الصعب القول انها تم القضاء عليها
بشكل كامل هناك مساحات ليس هناك سيطره
عليها بشكل او باخر وبالتالي لا استبعد ان
هناك استغلال لهذه المساله من اجل القيام
بهذه العمليه لكن في النهايه جلال هذه
العمليه عفوا فقط نقطه اخيره هذه العمليه
في النهايه جزء او هي رد رد على ما يجل
الان قطاع غزه رد على عدم وجود وضوح
للصوره من قبل الجانب المصري خاصه فيما
يتعلق او فيما يقال حول مشاركته في الحصار
على قطاع غزه خاصه في ظل كما قلت قبل قليل
الكلام الذي جاء قبل ايام من خلال محكمه
الدوليه حول انه انه معبر رفح تحت السيطره
المصريه هذا الامر في حاجه لتوضيح وتوضيح
شافي ووافي وكافي ليس فقط المصرين بل لكل
العالم ان هذا القطاع ان هذا المعبر يتم
ضربه بشكل مستمر قبل اسرائيل وان مصر
بالفعل يعني لا تقوم باغلاقه هذا الامر
يعتبر مهم جدا في هذه اللحظه الحرجه في
بسبب هذا الحادث الذي وقع قبل قبل فتره
قليله طيب